ukraine takes another step towards
joining the european union the bloc's
leaders say he should be granted
candidate status along with moldova but
membership talks could take years so
what happens now this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nick clark ukrainians are ready to
die for the european perspective that's
according to leaders of the european
union the executive arm of the 27-member
block is recommending candidate status
for ukraine along with moldova russia's
invasion has made the issue ever more
urgent but all members of the eu will
have to approve the candidacy at a
summit in brussels next week the leaders
of france germany and italy say they
will back ukraine's bid once approved
keeve will begin membership talks which
could take years to finalize the
european commission president says that
keeve's candidacy is conditional on
implementing reforms including tackling
corruption
in the view of the commission ukraine
has clearly demonstrated the country's
aspiration
and the country's determination to live
up to european values and standards
ukraine before the war had already
embarked
on its way towards the european union
for eight years now it had already been
gradually moving closer to our union
ukraine's president vladimir zelensky
called it a historic achievement
now we are only one step away from fully
fledged integration into the eu we have
a positive assessment from the european
commission concerning candidate status
for ukraine and it is a historic
achievement for all who work for our
country we just have to wait for the
decision of the european council next
week i think ukraine made everything
possible for this decision to be
positive so what about russia's
presidents well he says it's ukraine's
choice if it wants to join the eu but
warns kiev risks becoming what he called
a semi-colony
the eu is not a military alliance unlike
nato that's why we've always said our
position here is consistent and clear we
have nothing against it it's a sovereign
decision of any country to join an
economic alliance or not and it's up to
this economic union to accept new member
states or not
all right let's take a closer look at
the process to join the european union
countries first have to submit a
membership application to the eu council
it then assesses their ability to meet
the so-called copenhagen criteria and
this includes a functioning market
economy a stable democracy and the rule
of law as well as the acceptance of all
eu legislation and the euro
if the commission's opinion is positive
the council then begins to negotiate
membership often on a subject by subject
basis which can take years
five nations currently have eu candidacy
status albania north macedonia
montenegro serbia and turkey which has
been on the list for more than 20 years
all right let's bring in our guests in
cave we have alexander sheba who's a
former ukrainian ambassador to austria
in bratislava elena
director at the globe
policy institute and in brussels pieter
clepe an editor at brussels report dot
eu a website dedicated to european union
policy uh a warm welcome to each of you
uh piezo if i could start with you first
of all this recommendation of course
still has to be signed off by other
member states any doubt that it will get
through
um actually i think there's a good
chance now that it will uh will get true
uh denmark which was let's say one of
the the greatest opponents to ukrainian
accession
uh has has signaled that it would uh
support
uh ukrainian candidate status and also
the netherlands has done so
which is also let's say in the more
skeptic camp of course as has been
pointed out you know this is only the
very first step
um you know another step is whether to
open
actual accession accession negotiations
and then you know actual accession is a
very long way off there's many
conditions
to be attached to that and this is also
something that eu leaders will will
discuss
this week
all right elena do you think we would
even be discussing this candidacy
right now if it was not for the russian
invasion
i don't think so as you can see in the
case of the western balkans the
accession negotiations with many
countries have been effectively stalled
there for years for reasons that are
connected with the reforms dynamics in
the countries themselves but also with
the fact that the eu is increasingly
lukewarm about the enlargement policy
but definitely the war has changed the
geopolitical perspectives of the
european union and a lot of countries
even the ones that have been skeptical
for many years are now under pressure to
be more certain about what eu wants to
do and about what you can do in this old
neighborhood okay and alexander uh from
the ukrainian point of view how
important is it that this recommendation
comes at this time
when ukraine is at war with russia
well for ukraine it's huge it's very
important
i just remind you that in the year 2014
uh hundreds of thousands of ukrainians
when took to the streets when
then president yanukovych
made the decision he wouldn't sign the
association with
european union
and ever since uh it just we have been
showing how critical how important it is
for us and
what kind of sacrifice we are ready to
take upon us to walk the path towards
europe it's huge
yeah so you're saying that the people of
ukraine the vast majority of them anyway
wanted membership of the european union
before this war happened
of course it was uh
there have been doubts about
nato membership before uh
the annexation of crimea before 2014
but the uh
there were never doubts about
the population
uh about uh you know
eu membership as a strategic goal for
ukraine grain always had you know these
two
uh
to pass in front of her
russia and poland and poland has become
a success in the last
two or three decades russia hasn't it's
just as simple as that we just want to
be successful
and we don't want to be a country like
russia
your president alexander he says that
this recommendation and again it is only
a recommendation actual membership could
take you know several years it could
take decades uh he says
it will bring victory closer
will it
and how
this whole war is about spirit it's
about determination
uh
and it's not only our determination it's
all it's also
about you know the spirit of the outside
world of europe that seems uh to be
awakened now after years of this
so-called you know uh policy of
pragmatism uh which was uh uh hiding
very often
either at the coveredness or uh or uh
you know greek or uh foolishness now
finally uh not only ukraine is changing
europe is changing europe is seeing uh
what
what it means uh to really take values
seriously
europe sees uh that these are values
worth fighting for and they are not for
sale uh like unfortunately they often
were
uh
in european union in the last couple of
decades especially in the last decade
sure i i understand that i understand
that but it's just coming back to that
simple point that where president
zolensky says that this will this
recommendation will bring victory closer
i'm just wondering you know logistically
physically how can that happen
why don't we make our spirit stronger it
will make our spirit stronger it will
give us this sense of direction uh and
the sense of being recognized
understood uh so pieter if i can come to
you what's your view about this what
difference to the current battle does
this recommendation make do you think is
it about the symbolism
of the eu is is good for ukraine
well there's two um two aspects of it
first of all indeed it's sort of um a
moral uh expression of support for
ukraine you know we all know that on the
short term this this means very little
you know even in terms of money the
european union is sending lots of money
to ukraine anyway uh so so it's mostly
um a strong political signal but signals
are important uh to ukraine but secondly
it's also a signal to russia that um
you know
we will be the ones uh deciding um
whether we want to uh you know welcome
um countries in into our club of uh
democracies uh whatever you may think uh
of that
so you could say that um
there's a little bit of a risk involved
in that
but then russia has been making clear
that it's mostly concerned about nato
membership for ukraine which i think
will not be forthcoming at least for now
things may change even on that front
um but
russia has signaled that it would be
less uh worried about um
eu membership so so um i think um
it's um
it's all in all it's a good decision the
main downside is that you know um if the
war stops and if uh ukraine then uh you
know tries to uh improve and and and is
being rebuilt
um it may prove very hard for ukraine to
comply with the conditions so so i think
the european countries need to be very
clear not to give false hopes to ukraine
i think they already know it's important
to say look we definitely want you in
our club but this is gonna take a long
time given how much uh you know um work
you still uh need to do
alexander i can see you're shaking your
head there what's your view about this
this point that pieta makes about giving
false hope
well
we have been hearing this let's not give
uh ukraine false hopes for years and uh
i was hoping that finally it stops now
because if ukraine is not worthy of
being in the european family that is
defending so courageously right now
from this uh ferocious and insane uh
dictator in the east then who is and if
if
europe is hinting at ukraine's
corruption
then probably europe should look at
itself because ukraine was safe telling
europe for many many years who putin is
what did europe say did do they just
brush it off uh and uh continued doing
not always very transparent deals with
putin so in a way
uh europe owes ukraine because ukraine
was warning the world and europe for
many many years instead of that europe
was giving uh putin every possible uh
finance and every possible way to get
ready for the war we were saying he is
getting ready for the war and europe
made this war partly possible so let's
don't let's not overlook that
indeed elena
when president putin says that ukraine
is in danger of becoming a semi colony
what do you think he means by that
he repeatedly thinks that and he says it
repeatedly that ukraine is not a
sovereign country because supposedly
it's controlled from washington or from
the european union and so on but he's
been saying that about countries in
europe all along he doesn't think that
even europe is an independent continent
and no country in europe is supposedly
independent according to him because
they are allied with the united states
but what is interesting in ukrainian
case is that of course he's trying to
use this rhetoric to justify his
invasion and deny the legitimacy of
ukraine but this is exactly why european
union is making the move right now in
trying to make sure that ukraine
actually is a sovereign country ukraine
has a choice and its citizens are
allowed to make a choice whether they
choose the european path or whether they
choose the path of going with russia
putin doesn't like the choice that
ukrainians are making so of course he
has tried to delete the mind the choices
of ukrainians is there a danger that
this this eu recommendation elena will
will make putin more entrenched
putin is trying to say that everything
that the west does is uh
a denture for ukraine's prospects
supplying weapons for ukraine is a
denture providing any help to ukraine is
a denture but actually that means that
the you would should not be able to
provide any help to ukraine which is
definitely nothing fairies about it and
this is definitely not helping uh to
restore the rule of law in the
neighborhood so the one language that
putin does understand though is the
clear messages and the messages of power
he also said before that if he insists
on military neutrality of ukraine the
russians were saying that okay european
membership is something that they would
accept so this is also the way for you
for european union to call russian bluff
once again and make sure that ukraine
has the the candidacy offered at least
on the table before
any even potential discussions or
negotiations with russia can start right
and peter at the moment of course we
don't even know what shape what how what
the geography of ukraine will look like
by the time the
membership is is finally granted as when
and if and when it is and that
that in itself that kind of territorial
unknown is going to slow the process up
isn't it
uh yeah um that's indeed a major uh
concern now um what um i think uh is is
more important is what we were
discussing uh earlier um
because uh you know any serious talk of
your ukrainian membership is only gonna
is gonna happen when the war is over
hopefully soon of course
and then indeed we will know the actual
territorial shape of of ukraine
uh now um i do i do understand the
ukrainian concerns about you know false
of not of a false hope and that this is
often used as an excuse for you know
european countries that are afraid of
such a big country uh entering the eu
given all the power it would have the
fact that it would shift the balance of
power uh to the east
now actually recently french president
macron has been coming up with an
interesting initiative
to think a bit more profoundly of
some kind of a
you know
not not an alternative to eu membership
but a bigger association that is m much
more lighter that could uh serve as as a
waiting chamber for countries
that uh want to enter the european union
but that are not yet ready or for
countries like the united kingdom that
are not uh you know happy with the sort
of um
the great powers that the european union
uh has and uh you know perhaps we
already have an organization like that
it's called the european free trade
association efta
so
i mean i think that's something
especially ukraine should seriously
consider uh to to sort of uh reform efta
to make it a waiting chamber for the
western balkan 6 and for ukraine and to
have the united kingdom in it i think
that would definitely uh reassure you
well there's an idea let's put that
let's put that to alexander uh in kiev
alexander what's what's your thought
about that concept of a kind of waiting
chamber
it doesn't sound good
waiting chamber
you should think about a better name
first of all and second of all
i mean
again uh
this is what we heard uh in the last
couple of weeks from the countries uh
who
were hesitant about
opening uh doors for ukraine finding out
all kinds of you know
alternatives and that's another
alternative for uh instead of you know
embracing ukraine and seeing you praying
for it is uh a family for what it really
is a member of the family
one member of the family all of a sudden
uh europe wouldn't uh
would want some some chamber uh i don't
think chamber
is what ukrainians are bleeding now and
and dying for
uh and quite frankly about the point
that was made before about uh escalation
about uh putin's mood and putin's
uh you know uh ideas i think we are well
past that point and
we should have realized long ago
what would what was
clear for ukraine long time ago that
putin was getting ready for this war for
years if not decades and this is the
last imperial war he just brings the
colony back it's not about europe it's
not about nato it's just about bringing
back
he has this insane idea about the great
russian nation that consists of great
russians small russians i.e ukrainians
and white russians ai belarus belarus
and he wants to create this new soviet
union this is what this war is about and
eu perspective is absolutely marginal in
the head of this insane dictator okay
alexander i just just uh i'd like to ask
how hard do you think it will be for
ukraine once this war is over to to
honor those reforms those requirements
of the eu for membership you know the
rule of law reducing the power of the
oligarchs human rights and tackling
corruption and so forth
oh god
it will be a different
world after the war
everybody is talking about about that in
ukraine that once the war is over
we shouldn't rebuild the country we
should build a new country because
because all these saints of which we are
absolutely aware of
uh
they should be gone we should deal with
them and first of all corruption of
course second of all um
we should be more tolerant we should be
more uh embracing europe and embracing
minorities uh in ukraine there are
indeed the homework is there and it's
big it's long but believe me the mood in
the population is
first we win this war second uh we we
will get down to those reforms and
building a new country with the help of
europe elena i don't know if you want to
comment to that but uh also i'd like to
ask you the question do you think there
should be a fast-track
accession for ukraine in this process to
leapfrog those others that we were
talking about earlier
the eu commission has said already many
times and this is echoing the positions
of the member states that the accession
process will be merit-based that ukraine
will need to go through the reforms if
ukraine manages to go very fast for them
of course ukraine can join in a few
years and that would be very desirable
by everybody but the reforms will need
to be made and we need to be also very
honest here on the european side aside
the enlargement is not just about
ukraine or any other candidate country
it's also about the european union one
of the concerns one why people are a bit
uncertain about whether they want new
members or not at all is about whether
european union can absorb them including
whether the european union can be
efficient if we keep enlarging currently
european union makes most of the
decision by unanimity or consensus and
we if we keep adding more and more
members it's very unclear whether the
you will not become something
dysfunctional and unable to move forward
so part of this homework is also on the
u side to see what we can do but also
the discussion that we started about
this special weighting chamber there is
no consensus about how it could look and
what it would mean there is consensus
that the entire process takes very long
and there is consensus that there
shouldn't be any exceptions in terms of
waving countries through without them
making the necessary reforms but one of
the ideas that's also circulating is how
to make this accession in a way staged
for example if ukraine completes the
reforms let's say on digital services
why don't let ukraine be a full-fledged
member of some digital market or if
there is a completion of certain reforms
in the area of the energy portfolio
let's fully integrate ukraine in this
domain that would also help citizens to
feel that there's something tangible
that happens over all these years even
before ukraine can become the full
member let me put that to peter clipper
what do you think about that this kind
of incremental approach
i think it's a very interesting avenue
to to explore
and i think you could integrate uh with
uh with sort of my idea of
of uh of using efta again
as what it has always been
meant for
to sort of associate with countries that
are not a member of the eu
i do think ukrainians should appreciate
that the eu is a club that is very
powerful you know that is is deciding um
a lot of the regulations according to
estimates two-thirds of the impact of
all regulations in the european union
there's also massive financial transfers
within the eu
so so whether they like it or not the
truth is that many current member states
are wary to allow
newcomers into the club so so that's why
i think we have to be more realistic and
and indeed
sort of incremental uh you know opening
for ukraine to the eu
markets sort of methods like that okay
uh linking
right there because
we're just running out of time and i
just want to throw it back to forgive me
but i just want to throw it back to
alexander in about 30 seconds sir
so the eu meets next week what would be
your message to them
well
my message would be very simple we fight
for you guys
please see what we are doing
and
appreciate us
and
also admit
this war is you're doing too
thank you so much all of you for joining
us uh we could talk for
many more minutes and hours indeed but
thanks in the meantime to alexander
sherba elena cutsco and pieter klepe
thank you so much and thank you for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
just go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story and you can also join the
conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
nick clark and the entire team here in
doha it's goodbye
you